What is going on everyone? Welcome back
to another video. Today we are going to
be doing an IB and London 50 trade
review. Let's get right into it.
To start off, we're going to be
reviewing price action from January 5th
to January 9th. This past week, we did
have NFP. I ended up only having one
trade on the IB all week, and that was
Tuesday.
Before we get started, though, I want to
add in because I get this question so so
much.
What is preventing you from taking
trades? The IB, it did work for most of
the days this week. It needs to be lined
up with SPY. If this wasn't made clear
in the previous videos, it is now. When
you're taking the IB, it needs to be
lined up with what SPY is doing. So,
just zooming in on
Wednesday here, for example. We can
clearly see that Q's opened and it
pretty much just chopped sideways and
then eventually took the IB high, which
is what it was supposed to do. We had no
entry on this trade because if we also
go and review SPY's price action for
Wednesday,
it did the exact opposite.
Q's had a nice green candle to open,
sideways price action, consolidation,
popped right to the IB high. We go and
review SPY.
Small green candle,
big old red candle, targeting the IB
low, completely inversing what Q's was
doing. This is what prevents me from
taking trades on the IB. This is another
confluence to add into the strategy. If
you're not using Q's and spy, it might
interfere with what the win rate is on
the strategy.
Starting off with Monday, January 5th,
this was a no trade day. As I just
stated, we need Q's and SPY to line up,
and Monday was not it. As you can see,
we had a pretty big opening red candle
on QQQ, giving us a target of that IV
low to start. We ended up taking a new
IV high at about 10:30,
uh, maybe even 10:29, just before that
10:30 close and then it immediately took
the IB high in the following open. SPY
inversed that. We had a green opening
candle just continued to push up. Pushed
up really since 8:30 pre-market
cues pretty nasty. It did have a nice
reaction off London 50, but this was a
no trade for me on that day. This is one
of the harder things that goes along
with trading is being able not to trade.
If you look at these charts and you say,
"Yeah, I'm going to pick and choose
between spying Q's." That is not
trading. That's more on the lines of
gambling. You need this to be added
together for a A+ trade. You don't want
to go and pick and choose because one of
them might be right, one of them might
be wrong. The more 50/50 that trade is,
the more likely you are to lose.
Jumping to Tuesday, this was the only
day that we took a valid IB trade. We
had a beautiful bounce off London 50
after it was formed at 8:30 and 8:45.
continuation up over previous day's high
and we had a beautiful retracement to
50% after that IV was formed. I want to
add that when I was taking this trade on
Tuesday, I was itching to get into a
long prior to it retracing down to 50%.
With the way that we were moving, I had
no anticipation that we were going to
have any retracement. I thought we were
just going to break right through that
IV high. Managed to hold true, follow my
rules, waited for the 50% retracement.
entered and this trade ended up taking
two hours, but it was completely worth
it. It was a perfect representation of
what the Ivy strategy is meant to do.
Lined up with London 50 lined up with
London high. We had a $335 day times 25
accounts, these 20 Apex accounts as well
as five Tradeify accounts. And this was
as good as it gets. Perfect retracement
down. We did end up going a little
lower. I added, I believe, one at
61960ish
and then two and a half hours later, we
broke the IB high at 12:30. So, it was a
beautiful setup, beautiful trade. This
is exactly what you're looking for for
that IB.
Now, we're going to review that trade on
MNQ on Tuesday. It was an 85 point
reward, 85 point risk, one to one with
one MNQ. That's $170 to the IB break.
Yes, your risk is also going to be 170,
but this is just showing you that
there's no reason for you to go in with
ample size in that position.
You're, let's say, taking one NQ on this
trade, the wick down's probably going to
hit your DLL or even below your account
prior to even being able to run the
trade to the high. So, taking these
trades with one to 2 M and Q, $170,
$340, like what I ended up doing,
there's no reason for you to go in with
a crazy amount of size because the
trades, even though they do have a large
risk, they also have an equally high win
rate. Jumping over to Wednesday, I kind
of already reviewed this one, but this
was a nasty, nasty day. We had no trade
on this day as well. London 50 didn't
really do anything for Q's. We never
even retraced down to London 50. Uh even
pre-market after it was formed. We got
pretty close, but this one was another
one of those days where we had spy and
Q's do the exact opposite into open.
Funny enough, these actually both
fulfilled their IB trade. So Q's made
the IB low and then the IB high at uh 10
o'clock. Broke the IB high pretty much
right at that 10:30 open. So there was
no trade there. SPY was doing the exact
opposite with the IV high formed first.
IV low formed second at 10:15 and then
it went and within 10 seconds it broke
the IV low and immediately wicked back
up. Took the IV high. So ended up being
a double break on that day as well and
then went all the way back down, broke
the IV low.
As you can see, these two look pretty
opposite. Now they did happen to close
the day in the same direction.
But if you're looking at this again and
you're trying to pick and choose between
trading spy or trading Q's, you need
both of them to line up for you to get
into a trade. Now, before we review
Thursday, I want to add in another rule
that I'm going to anticipate moving
forward.
No trading pre-NFP. No trading on the
Thursday before NFP because this is the
type of price action that we're going to
get. I almost got a little tilted,
almost traded a little bit more than I
should have. I should have closed down.
I got a little annoyed that the IB
did retrace, ended up going about 85% of
the way to the low. I tried chasing a
little bit, almost turned a green day to
a red day. Ultimately locked out after I
got out of I don't know, one or two MNQ
on this trade. This one was nasty as can
be and it didn't end up breaking the IB.
The reason that I want to add in that I
did somewhat tilt on this day is because
I'm by no means perfect. There are still
days that happen like this. It digs at
me, gets to my emotions. I trade more
than I should as opposed to following my
rules. I al also want to add in that yet
again spy and Q's did the exact
opposite.
SPY hung out in its upper range of the
IB pretty much for the entire day. It
did end up breaking the IB high, which
is what it was supposed to do at 11:45.
Q's was targeting the IB low for the
entire day. Nasty price action again.
These two indices not lining up with
each other. So, no trade.
Finishing it off with Friday. This was
the perfect end to a terrible week of
price action. And that's obviously
sarcastic because this was yet again
another day where the IB broke prior to
us even being able to take it. No
retracement on the IB whatsoever. It
actually broke at 10:306.
There was no retracement whatsoever. It
broke 6 seconds after the IB formed. It
was NFP day. We had NFP at 8:30. We also
had pending news at 10 10:00 a.m. with
Trump's tariffs either being approved or
denied. that ruling ended up never
happening. We had a sweep down and then
just continued up for the entire day.
What I do want to add in for Friday
though, and this is a a really good tip
that has helped many people that I know
in trading futures, avoiding blowing
their prop accounts, whatever it might
be.
If you see the price trending in one
direction, 80% of the time it is going
to continue trending in that direction.
Only 20% of the time it's going to
pivot. meaning four out of five times,
eight out of ten times, price is going
to continue going to the upside. Two out
of 10 times it's going to reverse. So if
you're constantly looking at a chart
like this, if you're constantly looking
at trend days and you're saying to
yourself,
I don't want to go long. I'm going to
short it right here because there's no
way it's going to continue going up.
You're only going to win two out of 10
times on that thesis. So wait for a
pullback.
10:30, 11:15,
1:00,
probably not the one that's right at
close. All those pullbacks, those are
entries for you to jump back into the
trend. And as you can see, all three of
those ended up winning. Obviously, if
you took the one right at close, that
one did not end up winning.
Noticing the trend early is probably the
most difficult part with this. But if
you're at 1:00, 2:00 in the afternoon,
first off, there's no reason you should
be trading during that time frame. But
if you are and you see the trend has
been up for the entire day and you see a
pullback like this one:00 candle,
enter long on that pullback. Don't try
to inverse it and continue shorting to
the downside because eight out of 10
times it's not going to continue down.
It's going to look to continue in that
trend or continue to the upside.
To end off the video, I want to add in
that the IB on any given weekday is
about a 73% win rate, 72 to 76.
This week, we obviously only had one
viable setup and that was on Tuesday.
Monday did break through the high, so it
validated the IB. Wednesday, same thing.
Thursday never ended up breaking and
Friday ended up validating the IB high
even though it was at 10:30 in 6
seconds.
This strategy is going to print 96% of
the time.
Obviously, we're not entering every
single day because we have confluences
that need to get added up. SPY needs to
line up with whatever Q's is doing. We
also need to line up the London 50 or
maybe even previous days 50.
You need to get better at avoiding
taking non A+ setups. Meaning that if
you're trying to trade the IB or the
London 50 or inverse fair value gaps,
whatever your trading strategy is, if
you're trying to trade that every single
day because you feel like you have to,
you're going to end up blowing accounts
over and over and over again. I only
took one out of five trading days this
week.
Pretty crappy week for the IB, pretty
crappy week for the London 50. The data,
it ended up still lining up, but weeks
like this are going to happen. You need
to be able to not take a trade, not blow
your accounts, survive through the week.
Next week almost always has better price
action, especially when a week like this
happens. So, survive through the week.
Make sure that you're not taking those
non A+ setups. Better price action will
come. That will do it for today's video.
Hopefully, you guys enjoyed.
All the links to my socials will be in
the description. I will also add a
playlist to the IB50 and London 50 at
the end of this video. If you guys
enjoyed, drop a like, subscribe. I'll
see you next week.